it's finally here after weeks of rumors
and speculations Marvel just released
the first trailer for its upcoming epic
Avengers 4 here's an in-depth breakdown
of what you could be seeing in the
theater next year
The Avengers trailer for doesn't hint
much about the plot and said it focuses
on the opening act of the film setting
up where and what our heroes have been
doing since the devastating events of
Avengers infinity war Tony Stark and
nebula seemingly escaped Titan indepen
ATAR the ship that belongs to the
guardians of the galaxy the trailer
begins with Tony leaving a message to
his longtime girlfriend Pepper Potts it
was hinted several times throughout
spider-man homecoming and infinity war
that these two were getting married or
at least engaged Oh congratulations on
the wedding by the way that ring do I
I mean carrying this since 2008 Iron
Man's armor is badly damaged after the
epic battle against Thanos in Infinity
Ward and Tony and nebula are stranded in
space nearly out of oxygen food and
supplies it doesn't seem like they're
going to make it out themselves so who's
gonna rescue them will it be Carol
Danvers the Captain Marvel will debut in
her own film in March what could it
possibly be Pepper Potts herself Tony
Stark says in his message to pepper just
for the record being adrift in space
with zero promises rescue is more fun
that sounds could this be a hint to the
rescue armor in the comics a suit
designed by start that was made to be
worn by Pepper
Elite recently did show Gwyneth Paltrow
in an iron suit that closely resembled
the rescue armor
we'll just have to wait and see
[Music]
we also see a glimpse of Thanos into
trailer as well a recent interview
revealed that Thanos is not actually
residing on a planet but is in fact
within the soul stone one of the six
stones he collected during infinity war
the gauntlet still seems damaged from
the snap and appears he is still
carrying an injured arm we also got this
amazing shot of the armored scarecrow
which we had a glimpse of at the end of
infinity war a direct reference to
Marvel's
Infinity Gauntlet storyline back on
earth Captain America and Widow are back
in their Avenger space which looks
suspiciously abandoned we aren't sure if
the government has given up on them yet
or if it's the result of fantasies snap
but it seems like the Avengers won't be
getting a lot of help in defeating
panels we see Captain America without a
beard which could be a proof that there
might be a significant time gap between
infinity war and Avengers 4 we also see
him in the same suit that he wore in
Winter Soldier while talking to Black
Widow about a mission that simply has to
work this is gonna work Steve I know it
is cuz I don't know what I'm gonna do if
it doesn't what's really interesting is
the appearance of Peggy's photo there
have been countless rumors about
Avengers for dealing heavily with time
travel of course Hayley Atwell who
played capsule of interest Peggy Carter
denied any rumors of her appearance in a
movie but could this be a hint that the
Avengers will be traveling back in time
to save the world from Thanos Hawkeye is
back and he looks better than ever
it seems like the Black Widow travels
all the way to Japan to find him and
from the voice-over cues the lost
friends lost family
it looks like hawkeye's family has been
snapped away by Thanos leading him to
take on the role of Ronon based on his
costume Ronon was a secret identity that
Hawkeye briefly took on in the New
Avengers comics where he was seen using
a blade instead of a bow for his mission
in Japan the Avengers will need all the
help they can get to defeat the mad
Titan and hopefully we'll see Hawkeye
picking up his bow one more time we only
get one glimpse of both Hulk and Thor
looking severely distraught but more
importantly from this hologram that
Bruce is seen sherée seems to have been
the victim of thanasis snap as well a
surprising revelation given that Angela
Bassett said that both she and Sheree
survived the snap maybe not too
surprising given that another person
they thought was dead would make a
return Scott Lang disappeared into the
quantum realm at the end of ant-man and
the wasp it's not clear as to how but it
seems like he found his way out he's
seen asking cap and Widow to open the
door to what looks like the Avengers
base if the speculation about time
travel is true Scott and his knowledge
of the realm could play a vital role in
defeating Thanos and also it's just good
to have him back and finally Marvel has
revealed the title for the fourth film
endgame a direct reference to dr.
Strange's line in infinity war forming
out of the same type of dust that as his
victims turned into the title has been
under wraps for a long time and Marvel
didn't even include it in the title of
their video an even more good news the
movie will be opening April 26th a week
before its initial May 4th release date
so what did you think about this new
trailer what are your theories and
speculations leave them in the comments
and see you at the theaters in just four
months
you